talk Florence berley National ABS she
did her PhD at MIT um she's done a lot
of interesting work on Parallel Dynamic
andent algorithms and today she'll be
telling us about some of this recent
work thank you can everyone hear
me uh so yes thanks Julian um today I'll
be presenting my research in Dynamic
graph data structures as an example of
this higher level algorithm engineering
framework that I've been working on that
I'm calling the locality first strategy
so like I said the main focus of today
is on this question called Dynamic graph
data structures and uh the main focus of
these data structures is to support both
dynamic graphs and efficient query
answering for multicores I think
everyone in this room here probably
knows what a graph is but they represent
data with r disas and edges and they
underly many fundamental applications
and because they're everywhere there's
been a lot of work on efficiently
engineering these data structures
especially on multicores but for other
platforms as well these days large
graphs like Twitter can fit into the
primary memory on a single multicore so
we're interested in efficiently
processing them in shared memory and the
focus of this work is on optimizing them
for multi chourse the goal of these data
structures is to support the graphs an
efficient way to support queries or
algorithms that one might run want to
run on the graph so in this setting
queries are kind of complex for example
like bre for search or page rank or
between centrality like these classical
algorithms but you might be interested
in running many others and the goal is
to make these data structures run as
fast as possible support queries while
also supporting efficient
dynamicity these days multicores are the
most prevalent Hardware because they're
relatively cheap and accessible for
example you can rent a pretty big one on
demand from Amazon using just your
credit card when optimizing algorithms
and data structures on multicores there
are two main important features the
first is multiple cores for parallelism
and the second is the cach hierarchy
which requires developing cach efficient
codes so this is just an example of a
multi chip from Intel you can see that
most most of the area is taken up by the
multiple cores here and there's a sh
there's a shared L3 cache and all the
cores has have private L1 and L2 as well
so they have this pretty steep cach
hierarchy and this is great like you
have multiple cores you can take
advantage of parallelism uh but
unfortunately these two features also
make developing code for multicores uh
notoriously hard there's been a lot of
thesis on trying to develop fast codes
for these platforms and making really
good Pro progress in making it more
trable uh so to be a little more
specific to take advantage of these
Hardware features algorithms have to be
optimized for both parallelism and for
locality taking advantage of the
multiple course requires developing your
algorithm to scale well in parallel
which is notoriously hard um and
basically you want to do your operations
simultaneously and as many of them
simultaneously as
possible the second one is locality
which is this property of algorithms
it's the tendency of algorithms or
programs to access the same or similar
memory locations over time and people
have develop people have developed these
cash hierarchies to take advantage of
this natural property and algorithms but
one thing that you might often want to
do is trying to engineer your code to
become more cache efficient which is
hard because you need to know something
about the memory subsystem often unless
it's cash oblivious which is a separate
issue but those are also hard
um yeah so going back to grph for a
little bit that's kind of high level why
it's hard to do multicore engineering
there's several challenges especially to
doing these multicore data structures
for graphs the first is that graphs are
naturally sparse which is this property
where most of the edges are not present
for example in social networks if the
vertices are users and edges are
connections most of the users are not
connected to most of the other users for
example in a live Journal graph which is
this um popular graph for
experimentation there's about 5 million
vertices but the average degree is 18 so
almost all the edges edges are not
present and sparse graphs appear in
other domains it's as computational
biology and Road networks they all have
different shapes but they exhibit this
Edge
sparcity and sparcity is hard for
locality which is this property that we
want to optimize for because of the
presence of many zeros in your data
which affects how you would want to
represent it for example the most uh
straightforward representation of a
graph is an adjacency Matrix which we
might often be interested in for ease of
programming but if your data is few and
far between the adjacency Matrix is not
great for your locality of
data another part of the story is that
graphs are Dynamic which means that they
change over time for example if you have
a social network you might want to or
delete connections and systems for these
graphs have to support updates Edge
insertions and deletions as well as
queries which are these algorithms that
you want to run on the graph and
supporting these Dynamic R is
challenging because there's sort of this
inherent tension between locality and
update ability that I'll get into a
little more later but kind of at a high
level the intuition is that if you put
your data close together if you want to
modify it it's more annoying because you
have to move more stuff
around so despite these challenges to
optimizing locality and dynamic graph
data structures there's been significant
effort devoted to Frameworks for these
graphs by a lot of folks in this room
one recent shiny example is Aspen which
is a really cool piece of algorithm
engineering um it's really fast it's
beautiful actually and it beats Dynamic
existing Dynamic graph Frameworks by
several orders of magnitude both in
terms of updatability and in query time
and this is just an example on how fast
Aspen which is something that I did not
make uh can run these queries on Twitter
so it can do breath research in.3
seconds can do page rank in 24 seconds
and it can do between the centrality in
4.7 seconds uh this is already really
fast like this is several seconds but of
course we're always interested in
engineering things to make them faster
because for algorithms like the graphs
are getting bigger and you might often
want to change several of these
algorithms together in some sort of
analysis
pipeline um so my co-authors and I
introduced a system called terce which
is a novel Dynamic graph data structure
built around this uh this framework that
I'm talking about called the locality
first design and first I want to show
some results about what happens when you
use this method this is this flat the
yaxis is normalized speed up of Terrace
over Aspen which is already fast the
line at one is equivalent and the x-axis
is just the several algorithms that we
tried so breath for surge page rank
between a centrality and connected
components up is good um above one means
that Terrace was faster than Aspen and
you can see that in these cases these
are averaged over several data sets but
in these cases terorists often exhibit
speed up over Aspen
and both of them run both systems run
the same algorithm because they
implement the same high level algorithm
framework and surprisingly in some cases
terce actually achieve speed of over Lia
which is a static system um and that is
surprising because often you have to pay
something for your dynamicity in your in
your algorithm performance um but in
some algorithm cases you actually don't
if you do this locality
optimization do you have to re-engineer
the algorithm to use your um framework
or or is it like you can plug in yeah
it's a really good question so the
question was do you have to re-engineer
the algorithms to plug into the
framework or I guess like the data
structure yeah
um or did you do that in this case so we
separately implemented the lra
abstraction uh it's called like Edge map
vertex map abstraction and one really
nice thing about it is that it lets you
write simple Primitives that you can
hook into your data structure and as
long as you implement the simple
Primitives uh you can hook in any data
structure one thing that I'm currently
working on uh is trying to make that
even more widespread so it's a really
good question um and one challenge in
this area is like doing Fair
comparations between data structures
because like the algorithms and data
structures are somewhat orthogonal and
like you can imagine doing direct
implementation of these algorithms and
like writing your data structure
underneath then it's hard to compare
them
so so that was query
performance uh sorry along this line so
how much is a difference in between
let's say and connected components uh in
terms in the in the abstra in the
algorithm abstraction framework not much
like the impl like ter you impl in terce
you only have to implement The
Primitives we use the lier abstraction
and the LI section determines the
algorithm like it's sort of like a
frontier type thing so that um the
algorithms are pretty short like usually
they're about 100 lines or less and if
you implement The Primitives through
some layer of obstruction you can
Implement some simple things like math
basically Down Below in your dat
structure
level so that was algorithm
performance and the second in comparison
when doing these Dynamic data structors
is update ability so one thing that you
don't really want to do or like one
thing that is not ideal is to do really
well in your algorithms but then pay for
it in terms of your updates because then
you're just somewhere else on this
trade-off curve
um so it is important to also measure
the insertion throughput and also
deltion but it's not here so here the y
axis is insertion throughput up is good
the x-axis is batch size and often in
these data structures we add edges in
batches which is like you have 100 or a
thousand edges that you might want to
add at once there's different ways that
you can Implement these batches terce
happens to implement them concurrently
but you can do something which is that
La we'll talk about more in detail later
which is called batch Dynamic which is
you implement them all as one Atomic
operation on your data ructure and the
main point that I want to make here is
that the Terrace line is this green one
the Aspen line is this brown one and the
green one is mostly higher than the
brown one except for the very last point
because Aspen does scale better for
large batches um and that is something
that we are working on in terce but for
almost all the batches terce is pretty
good relative to
Aspen so now that we saw the results I
want to explain how we got there this
work in graph data structures shows that
to to create these efficient
multi-course Solutions we as algorithm
developers and Engineers might consider
using something that I'm calling this
locality first strategy this is like a
temporal order for us to use when doing
algorithm engineering so the first step
is to identify a problem that you might
be interested in engineering this
problem that we just talked about is
dynamic graph data structures the next
step is to understand the locality in
these Dynamic graph data structures and
then try to exploit it once you
understand what is possible in the
problem and then only at the end to add
back in the Paralis so in the end we
want both locality and paralis optimized
codes because you can't achieve Peak
Performance without both but this is
just a temporal order to follow because
you have to pick something to do
first as I mentioned before locality is
this core property of algorithm access
patterns there are two main kinds that
have been studied for decades the first
one is spatial locality which is how
many accesses an algorithm makes to
nearby data over a short time so ideally
you want to access contiguous memory
locations like for example reading an
array in memory is much faster than
reading pointers like in a link list or
something and the second one is temporal
locality which is how many repeated
accesses you make to the same data over
time um and spatial locality takes
advantage of things like cash lines
whereas temporal locality takes
advantage of things like uh your cach
levels like L1 L2 and such and so that's
what I mean by hierarchical access and
temporal locality is something that you
often change well both of them are
something that you often change your
code to optimize for but when you want
to understand the locality in your
problem it's important to first
understand like what are the
options so going back to graph
processing uh it turns out that if you
want to optimize for queries in graphs
whether dynamic or not uh it turns out
that spatial locality is a main concern
when doing that and one really cool
thing from the Lio work is this
abstraction of several graph algorithms
that allows us to express them in terms
of something called vertex scan which is
this processing of a vertices incident
neighbors this is two examples of graph
algorithms the first one is breath first
search that you might learn in any
undergrad algorithms course the way it
works is that you get a graph you have
your source and you have a queue and you
put your Source in the queue and while
you still have stuff in your queue you
look at the front you look at all the
neighbors of the stuff that you just
eqed and then you explore them if they
haven't yet been explored and the main
work in that was iterating through all
these neighbors because everything else
is just kind of simple management and
that is what I mean by scan
the second example is triangle counting
which is counting Edge triangles in your
graph and the most simple algorithm to
do that is you just look at all the
edges in your graph and you have U andv
and if they have a shared neighbor W
then you add to your triangle count uh
and doing this intersection one simple
way to do it is if your neighbor lists
are sorted you just do like this two
finger scan and you just count it
neighbors so that again is this vertex
scan and in the first example you don't
have temporal locality because you only
iterate through every neighbor list at
most once and in the second one you
might have temporal locality but the
point is that you don't know if you're
going to iterate through them more than
once so you have to optimize in your
data structure level for spatial
locality because the algorithm is sort
of like at a higher level and you're not
totally sure exactly what access pattern
it
has and the spatial locality of the scan
operation depends on your graph
representation so optimizing for scans
boils down to choosing the right data
structure so for for concreteness this
is an example graph with my co-authors
um it's a pretty simple graph but let's
say that we want to represent this
vertex here and we're trying to
represent the outgoing edges so two
simple representations that we can
choose for this neighbor list is
uncompressed which is basically one row
of an adjacency Matrix and Edge array
which is basically one segment of your
compressed spse rows and in uncompressed
you have a number of in the unweighted
case you have a number of bits equal to
the possible uh to the total number of
vertices in the graph and then you set
zero if there's no connection and you
set one if there is a connection and in
edray instead of doing this implicit
storage you actually just directly write
down the neighbors so here we wrote like
these two are the connections so we
write two and three and these are like
pretty simple representations but uh
this shows what I was talking about
earlier more concretely which is that if
your data is sparse this representation
is hard for your locality because you
have many zeros um and so your data is
far apart and your scan is proportional
to the number of vertices no matter how
much actual stuff you have in
there um however in this Edge
representation you get better efficiency
on queries if you actually write down
the neighbors if you have sufficient
sparsity so here the scan is
proportional to the number to the degree
of the vertex which is great if the
degree is much less than the number of
vertices um so if you only cared about
algorithm performance You' be pretty
much done here this is basically this
classical compressed par R
representation uh and you would be right
but however you want to do updates also
and so for example like we were here and
let's say we want to add an edge to zero
and going back to these representations
we set the bit at zero in uncompressed
so your update is order one because you
just have to flip the bit uh in Edge
array however it's harder because if you
want to keep these in sorted order like
for triangle counting in the earlier
example you have to shift everything
down which is now proportional to the
degree which is not great for arbitrary
degree so even these two simple data
structures exhibit this tension between
between scan and update performance and
kind of the main question of these data
structures boils down to how to do
fancier data structures to support both
F scan and
update uh like I said sta the-art
systems might use more advanced data
structures but they still have this
tension from the previous slides folk
wisdom about Dynamic graph data
structure says that you have a trade-off
between query and update performance
this is just a cartoon but like quer
performance update performance up is
good right is good uh and in the extreme
for Aesthetics just systems for example
lra the query performance is really good
but like they don't support updates so
um and On The Other Extreme you have
highly dynamic system such as Aspen and
the update performance is really good
but compared to legra the query
performance is not as good I mean this
is like it looks far in the cartoon but
in reality it's not actually like that
far it's just for illustration um and
like I was saying terce achieves good
query and update performance the query
performance is comparable to lras and
the update performance is comparable to
aspin by designing these C Fusion data
structures um so like I promised we're
going to understand what is the
opportunity for optimizing locality so
we understood that we're going to
optimize for spatial locality so the way
that most of these Dynamic graph data
structures are currently designed is in
this two-l structure um and this op this
design is really good for paralyzation
because you have one level for your
vertex IDs basically each of these has a
pointer to a separate container for the
neighbor list it's really good because
you get to do paralyzation over the
vertex IDs and you don't you might not
even necessarily care so much about the
parallelism in the lower level which is
kind of harder to implement this is the
highle structure that underlies a lot of
these fancier data structures like trees
adjacency list and others like you can
move you can make these boxes pretty
much anything you want they don't have
to be even the same thing um so you get
really good paralyzation but one problem
in terms of optimizing for spal locality
in this design that if you wanted to do
in some algorithms you do want to do
like an edge scan over the entire thing
like in page like uh in the most simple
version of page rank you do like a scan
over the entire thing and you have to
incur cash Miss at the edge of each of
these neighbor lists um which is not
ideal for your locality so that's one
possible way that we could improve
it so going back to this high level
strategy we started with the problem we
understood the locality potential in it
and now we're going to exploit it using
fancier data
structures so like I said this highle
design that underlies a lot of these
data structures is you have two levels
one is appointed to all these containers
and you have a bunch of separate
containers and the first step that my
co-author and I took to trying to
improve the locality is to collocate all
of these neighbor lists into one giant
data structure and um so this solves the
cache misses that you get in between the
vertices when reading all the edges but
but uh it does introduce some issues
because if you want to do concurrent
updates to multiple different labor
lists now you have to deal with the
concurrent data structure on the bottom
level uh whereas here you could just do
them separately in parallel so uh it
does introduce some issues so you do
have this again this tension between
locality and updatability but it turns
out that because this is contiguous and
computers are really good at doing stuff
in contiguous memory uh the updates in
here are still okay and that was our
first paper on
pcsr and one question that this design
raises um I guess both during and after
we were working on this is that like
whether these misses that I'm talking
about at the end of the neighbor list
actually affect your performance or
whether they're just kind of like a low
order term because you do have to in
some algorithms like access access the
entire graph and so you might depending
on the structure like if you if you
thought or like one kind of thought
experiment is like if all your neighbor
lless oh I'm sorry go
ahead uh I could finish the slide and
then you CSR there but then at the
bottom you have packed memory array and
I'm just wondering like where is it like
I see CSR and I think how is that
different than CSR but it is a P memory
array that you're using yes it's a good
question so this thing uh if this was an
array this would be CSR right and if
this is a packed memory array this is
pcsr okay so PP CSR is a packed memory
array yes like a top level s and I guess
for folks on the screen the question was
what is the difference between this
picture on the right and
CSR so um basically what I was saying is
that one thought experiment that we can
do is if all the neighbor lists are of
huge size like if they were a million or
10 million for example you wouldn't
really care so much about the edge
condition at the end because you're
already reading so much data like saving
one cash Miss is not going to help you
that much but if they were tiny like in
the extreme like if they one then you
would actually care so a lot of this
depends on the structure of your graph
and it turns out that yes it does
actually help you because of this
natural structure of real world graphs
uh they're they naturally exhibit the
skewed structure um or like power law
degree distribution where you have a lot
of low degree vertices and a few High
degree vertices so this is a cartoon of
I guess Twitter the y- axis is the
frequency of occurrence the x-axis is
the number of followers you might have
I'm here somewhere and Taylor Swift is
here somewhere um I don't like most
people are kind of like me where we
don't have many followers but you have
these few heavy vertices and if you run
some statistics you can see like on
Twitter uh over half of the vertices
have fewer than 10 neighbors and almost
all of them have fewer than a thousand
neighbors um so most of the cases that
most of the neighbors or most of the
vertices have pretty low degree so you
do actually care about this Ed condition
but the variance is very high like the
Maxes in the
millions um so the next step uh we
started with ppcs which is collocating
everything into one giant data structure
and that's this picture on the left the
problem with this initial design is that
the high degree vertices slow down
updates for everyone so like if you want
to add verticy into or if you want to
add degree to a heavy vertex um the time
uh everybody else has to deal with the
heavy vertex in your data structure and
so this refined solution is using this
hierarchical design that Coates low
deegree vertices for improved spatial
locality in cases where it actually
matters relative to the to the degree
and separating out higher degre vertices
where you already have to read so much
data that it doesn't really matter uh
that you save one or two cach misses and
then trying to optimize the update
ability in
those and terce implements this
hierarchical skew Weare design using a
shared PMA and a standalone B tree a PMA
is a dynamic array based data structure
and a b tree is a dynamic tree based
data structure and B trees are ASM
totically optimal while pmas are not
but uh it turns out that if you use this
but you know in practice like the
theoretical bounds as I will show you in
a second are not exactly what they
seem um and the reason for this
multi-level design is this practical
trade-off between pmas and berries so
the theory tells us that berries are
always better or match pmas in terms of
the astics in the classical caching
models so if you only cared about the
theory you would pick be trees and be
done with it um however the reality is
more complicated because in practice
neither is better for the operations
that we care about in all aspects so um
this waxes is doing some just like a
couple of micro benchmarks with PMA and
B tree wax is PMA over B tree runtime so
this dotted line is at one and above one
means that the PMA was slower and Below
one means that the PMA was faster
compared to the B tree the yis or x-axis
is just the number of elements in the
data structure and these three lines are
the classical data structure operations
get insert and
scan and um you can see that the B3 is
better for get and insert because this
line is above one and the PMA is better
for scan because that line is below one
and the reason for this is that the
classical caching model doesn't take
into account the difference between
sequential and random cache access so in
the regular external memory model every
any arbitrary memory block access has
cost unit cost but it turns out that in
reality accessing accessing adjacent
memory blocks is faster than accessing
random memory blocks and there are more
advanced caching models that take this
into account like the FI model for
example has some parameter that takes
that into account but uh those are not
yet as widespread as the traditional
caching models so that is one
interesting Direction I guess which just
like to think about how we might use the
fener models and whether that captures
what we see in reality or whether those
models also need refinement but yeah
anyway going back to graphs the the the
problem with this is that neither data
structure is a clear winner for the
operations that we care about and the
solution is in ter just use both
depending on the
degree so now we have this background to
understand how terorist takes advantage
of spatial locality as a further
optimization for a locality terce store
some of the edges in place as an
additional optimization um like if the
degree is very low then you can just
store them in place in some type of
array you don't even need to go to a
separate neighbor list but that's kind
of like a doesn't fit as well into the
story that I was trying to tell um and
this is just a measurement of cach
Misses on the live Journal graph to
understand um this thing that I was
talking about in locality we have three
systems we have ligra Aspen and Terrace
Aspen and terce are Dynamic and we
tested this on two algorithms breath
research and Page Rank and basically the
only point I want to make here is that
uh these numbers are relatively smaller
than the other ones because of these
cations
um yes
question it's a very good question so
the question is what is the space usage
uh terce is bigger than Aspen for
several reasons one is uh the PMA uses a
constant factor of Extra Spaces while B
trees use ASM totically less than a
constant factor of extra space also uh
the implementation of aspin is
compressed they use Del compression
whereas the current implementation of
ter is not compressed but that is
something that we're working working on
and I think it would be a really
interesting
Direction so uh the results that I was
showing at the very beginning show that
terce is about twice as fast on
algorithms compared to Aspen with
similar update ability and the cool
thing about these results is that the
main driver is this uh this locality
first method for optimizing uh for
engineering practical algorithms that
enhance your spatial locality in this
case but in general all kinds of
locality in other cases uh and in the
end like notice that I didn't really
talk about the parallelism at all but
all these systems do happen to be
parallel because they wouldn't be uh
really competitive with each other
otherwise and um the Cod is at the skum
and uh I want to maybe like switch gears
a little bit so we just finished there's
kind of two parts to this talk there's a
surprise second part uh the first one is
this Dynamic graph data structures using
this locality for strategy so we kind of
walk through a case study and I want to
talk a little bit about stuff that I'm
more recently working on in this area
but first I can stop for
questions so I mentioned briefly um
about this batch parallel model for data
structures where you have so there's
kind of like two ways that you can do
updates on your data structure the first
one is concurrent which is like a
classical model for key value stores
other kinds of data structures the
second one is bch parallel which is you
have a set of updates that you want to
make and you make them into one Atomic
operation on your data structure and you
can algorithmically support those um
Often by Union and yeah so because often
B P implementations are faster than
thecurrent concurrent counterparts
there's been a lot of work in developing
efficient best parallel set
implementations which are the underlying
thing for like you can build any graph
data structure out of an efficient set
because you just make the set like one
of the boxes that I was showing in the
high level design so there's been a lot
of work on doing these fast batch
parallel sets and maps and the main
bottleneck in the parallel scalability
is not necessarily if your B size is big
enough it's not necessarily the
parallelism it's kind of like the memory
subsystem limitations because just like
that's kind of It kind of like always
happens in multicores if you're like
data set is big enough that you run into
these memory scalability issues and yeah
and so like people have done a lot of
cool stuff to try to try to get around
this mostly compressing the data
structure but also doing other tricks
and one thing that I'm interested in
working on and have been doing is to use
this cach friendliness of pack memory
arrays with algorithmic support for
batch insertions and deletions so
um the thing in terce was concurrent but
it could be way faster if you had Direct
algorithmic for vatch updates and the
problem with developing these algorithms
for pmas uh is that existing algorithms
are mostly for pointer based things like
skip list or tree so existing algorithms
don't Port super easily to the array
model because they often rely on pointer
Union like trunion and pointer
adjustment uh and this picture is
trunion guess I think I'm confused what
was the difference between batch
parallel and the
concurrent uh so the question is what is
the difference between batch parallel
and concurrent um in concurrent all the
updates happen in parallel to each other
but like every update is an atomic
operation like every single insertion
whereas in bch
parallel uh the group update is one
Atomic operation you say like for
example for a batch size of 100 you
would say I have 100 updates and I want
to do those in one single Atomic
operation on my data structure so you
can do something like tree Union
basically whereas you cannot do tree
Union for the concurrent world because
like the entire Union or like each
update is not concurrent to each
other
sorry why does treat un need help I
guess I I don't have
enough I see um the reason is that uh
for efficient paralyzation often you
need enough kind of like enough work to
paralyze over like paralyzing each
single like each of these insertions is
like log time so like paralyzing within
the insertion is often not really
helpful uh so if you get if you get to
be in the batch world you get to
paralyze over the entire Dutch and you
get to like uh modify you get you kind
of like have some guar anes where you
can modify parts of your data structure
with nobody interfering with you right
so you don't have to do like in currency
control for example
right uh so I have been working on this
a little bit uh so one thing this is
currently on archive we made cpma which
is a compressed fact memory array with B
insertions uh and this is I think I
think it's a little cool because like a
lot of the B parallel sets are pointer
based I think almost all of them are um
so it's not so like up front it wasn't
actually clear that this would be better
but uh so here's some data the Y the
left side is batch insertions the y axis
is throughput the xaxis is batch size uh
there's four lines one is PMA one is
cpma both PMA and cpma have batch
insertions there's UPAC and CPAC uh
which is very recent uh it's in a
library called cpam but uh I don't call
it CPM because that's just like edit
distance one for CPM
so um I'm calling it UPAC which is
uncompressed factories and CPAC which is
compressed factories and there are four
lines and the main point that I want to
make here is that the compression
improves the like the yellow one is
compressed and the blue one is
uncompressed for the pack memory aray
and the yellow one is higher than the
blue one and both are higher than the
other ones except for the last one again
um and this one is range queries so the
only reason that we actually would ever
want to use pmas is because if you have
some kind of skin based workload because
the PMA is basically an array so you
want to scan over a large part of it
otherwise like if you're doing update
only often you just these trees uh so
here for range queries yis is throughput
X xsis is like size of your range query
um again these two kind of
like xar lines are CMA cpma and PMA and
these are tree and in the limit they
kind of converge a little bit because it
actually turns out I think the default
node size in CPAC is pretty big so
uh yeah so that's why they're pretty
close in the limit
but the gpma does have the advantage of
being anra so it is f SC so this is kind
of interesting I think because there's
often a trade-off between insertion and
skin um but it turns out that using
batch insertions you can in the in the
PMA and cpma you can overcome a lot of
this
tradeoff and I'll tell a little bit
about how you do it so
PMA insertions um a PMA is a array based
data structure and there's several steps
to doing a PMA insertion so like let's
say you have this array and the way that
a PMA works is it's basically an array
with spaces inside it so you don't have
to shift everything around on every
insertion and so I want to insert this
number 22 so first I look for where I
would put 22 which is here I do like a
binary search and then you place 22 so
here you would put 22 in its order in
orted or like in its location orted
order and then the main one of the main
properties of this is that you have to
maintain some notion of density and any
in all of these segments and so after
you do an insertion you have to count
your segment and if you violate your
density band you have to count your
neighbor segments and do some
redistribution so here in this example
the density band is 0.9 and I count this
segment and I find that the density is
one which is higher than 0.9 so I count
my neighbor and I find that the density
is 0.5 and you can equalize them to both
both satisfy the density bound so that's
what redistribution is you put some of
the elements from the Overflow segment
into the less flow segment so now 15
moved here and both of them are
happy so that's how Point insertions
work in PMA and like uh this is an
example for two segments but if your
arrays of arbitrary size then you
basically build a binary tree on these
segments and that that's how you do the
redistribution so it is not clear how to
do Union in
arrays because there's no pointers in
this
inion and the high level way that this
multi insert works is kind of how you
might imagine it through batch merges um
so instead of inserting one element this
batch insertion has now three elements
that you want to add so example like 15
22 89 and let's say I have this PMA with
some empty slots in it and uh to do the
batch insertion I
search for all or for the segments that
these elements would go into and I find
that they all go into the segment um
which is a little unfortunate because
there's not enough slots for all of them
like there's only two empty slots and
there's three things that I want to add
so this is one subtlty which is like you
have to uh if you're doing batch merge
you might not have enough space for it
and so uh one thing that we did is like
in this batch merge phase you might have
to use some external storage or like
some other out ofpl storage to store the
thing that you want to merge and then
this five is just the number of elements
in your out ofpl storage but counting
still kind of works the same actually
counting now is easier because you just
divide this over the number of slots
that you have if you know that you have
out ofpl storage and again like this 0
25 is less than 0.9 but this 1.25 is
higher than 0. n so you want to do this
Equalization and so you move some
elements from this out ofpl storage into
uh into the less full neighbor uh the
most hard part of this which I'm not
going to get into is that doing this
counting work efficiently is subtle um
traditionally in the concurrent world
you might have to if you counted them
concurrently at a high level you might
have to like re different threads might
recount the same area if you're not
doing efficient caching uh so one thing
that the main I guess like the main
algorithmic challenge is to do this work
efficiently
but the actual batch merging is really
fast because it's just moving a raise
room just are you do you make an
assumption that the size of the batch is
smaller than like I guess the contiguous
sub segments that you're looking at the
question was do you have to assume that
the size of the batch is smaller than
the segments uh no in this case uh if
this was like larger than the segment
you would the outer playay storage is as
big as you want and so you would just
write how many elements are in the
outplay storage like it could be that
your batch is gigantic and they all go
to the same place but then you would
just use this large out a place array
and then you would write the number of
elements in there and then you would
redistribute over a bigger area
potentially than uh the way that P
insertions work is that like if you find
that your neighbor doesn't have enough
space to hold all your elements for them
both to be happy you like go up one
level in the tree and you keep going
until you find one that can make
everyone happy or you just have to
double the entire
array
cool um okay so one reason that we were
interested in doing this is that like I
said uh the main issue in the scal
scalability is often not the parallelism
but the um but the memory bandwidth and
so the batch insertion algorithm that I
just showed you is for pmas but you can
easily translate into compressed pmas
and so we did some this is just
classical parallel scalability this line
is cpma this line is PMA uh and and this
is the number of threads and the cpma
has higher parallel scalability than the
PMA because you have to just move fewer
bites around um and you kind of see a
similar thing for the range
queries how much smaller is cpma
compared to P based on this left plot
seems that this uh difference is
significant I guess like the the speed
up cannot be more than the difference in
size yeah it's a good question so the
question is like how much smaller is
cpma compared to PMA
uh it depends on how many elements you
have in it but uh if because like if
they're closer together then your
compression ratio is better um we often
saw compression ratio like almost around
three or four three or four right for
sufficiently large data set
size yeah so to bring it back to graphs
uh one cool thing about the cpma that
you can do is that you can think of your
graph is just one sort one giant sorted
Edge list where you have like U andb as
two parts of your uh two parts of your
edges and if you think of if you put
them in if they're less than 32 bits you
can use 64 bits to store both the source
and the destination The Source in the
upper 32 and the destination in the
lower 32 uh and you can also do this if
you have more than 32 bits but you just
need two can't need two 64 bit things
together uh and in you can store this
list in one single cpma and if you use
compression so like for example you have
these edges like UV UW ux and this is
how you would store them in a PMA in 64
bit chunks so like each of these is 32
bits so you have like UV UW ux and with
Del compression you often Allied out the
source so you have U which is your
Source but and then you have V which is
the like your neighbor I guess uh but
then you have like wus V and xus W and
then since you subtracted out each of
these chunks you got rid of you uh in
almost all the rest of them can you
store zero in zero bytes so how can you
store zero and zero
bytes
uh I think you have to use one bite to
store zero I think the minimum space per
thing is one
bite uh well for bite codes but like you
can use smaller codes like you can use
like four four bit or two bit than one
bit but I think they tried those in lier
plus and they weren't very
fast that's why we stuck to
e uh yeah and then we tried this for
dynamic graphs um so in the CPAC paper
they also do it for dynamic graphs and
then we did some several algorithms so
this left side is algorithms uh up is
good this is algorithm and F graph is
the one aray thing that I just showed
you uh the f is for flat I guess um and
this one is update speed up is good Y is
throughput xaxis is f size and now that
fgra has actual algorithmics batch
updates the batch updates are comparable
to
CPAC um so let's wrap this up despite
this theoretical prediction that pmas
are worse than b trees or cash friendly
tra you P empirically can overcome this
tradeoff by doing locality based
optimizations and this is just again
like a similar catmas cable that I was
showing earlier this is L1 and L3 this
is UPAC which is uncompressed CPAC which
is compressed PMA and cpma this is
uncompressed this is compressed um I
guess like the interesting comparisons
are like this and like this and so PMA
has more cach misses than cpma and both
of them have fewer cach misses than even
the compressor because it is contiguous
and and so it gets to do really fast
skins and yeah you can find the details
here and yeah thank you so one thing
that I'm really excited to talk to folks
about here is this relationship so I
talked a lot about like Dynamic graph
containers uh which is how you actually
store the graph but I want to know more
about the relationship between the
container and the dynamic graph
algorithms which are actually really
data structures but that's okay um so
like obviously to do the algorithms you
have to store the graph in in some kind
of container and you have to choose a
container but like is there also a
container question in the dynamic graph
data structures which are called
algorithms
um yeah so I love to talk to folks about
that thank
[Applause]
you any
questions um so um you use some kind of
portfolio
El so you used some kind of portfolio
type approach um oh I think
it's use some kind of a portfolio type
of approach for um for choosing like
which data structure you use based on on
the degree I guess was this always like
you know could you extract a clear rule
of thumb or is there some potential for
using some I don't know more data
science or machine learning typee of um
thing that predicts like when you should
use which data structure the question
was
um live stream
here
either okay yeah so really quick the
question was like could you kind of
choose the cut off in a smarter way
maybe um in Terrace and I think it's
really interesting we currently the way
we did it is just like some very simple
heris stic based on the memory block
size I think like between the in place
level and the PMA level is just like a
cach line or two and then between the
medium level and the big level is like a
page size uh we did like a little
experimentation around those areas like
within maybe a few powers and found that
it didn't really affect things that much
just because like the variance is so
high that like the really heavy vertices
are so much heavier than the than
everything else um but I do think that
there could be a smarter definitely a
smarter selection um and maybe even more
data structures like there's I guess
there's nothing like magical about two
or three um if you did have a reason to
explo different
tradeoffs I have F questions so you
mentioned um that your data structure is
concurrent um do you use like a lock to
support concurrent updates or do you
have some other way to do it uh yeah so
uh the question was like how do you do
the concurrency the PMA uses locks
within because it's one single shared
PMA and the B trees are separate so you
can just lock the entire B tree um but
one thing that I think you could to make
it faster is to make it a concurrent B
tree or even a batch B tree but then
you're in the batch
World
thanks
okay one more
question
sorry question about
like you is the graph uh data structure
you use
say the is it for a you know main memory
data structure that you use for a
specific application or do you
anticipate like that it could be the
same graph could be used for maybe many
different computations maybe different
from the applications you have seen here
so so H how much of your design is based
on the
specific algorithm or problem you want
to solve rather than I just have a
generic graph data structure and maybe I
may run many different algorithms on it
I see um so the question is like how
much of the design is based on the in
some like the algorithm uh using the
scan obstruction you can express like a
huge variety of algorithms I think in
not in like one of the followup papers
they do maybe even like 20 or 30
algorithms that you can use with scan
obstruction and a little bit of other
stuff so I think that the variet like
the the base idea for what you're
optimizing for is pretty uh pretty wide
depending on the kind of algorithm that
you might want to run um one really
interesting thing that if anybody has
ideas that I love to talk about is like
even more like Downstream applications
so like right now we have this Leger
framework and we can run algorithms and
maybe the algorithms can plug into some
even bigger Downstream application that
uses those as component or maybe does
other stuff and then it might be that in
those other applications you might care
about other things besides skin um
another thing that I think Bill was
talking about earlier is like uh
this maybe like we are currently
optimizing for both update and scan but
one question that I'm not sure that
anybody really knows yet is like uh like
we know like how fast the edge
insertions come but I don't think that
corresponds necessarily to the
underlying graph representations because
like I think like for example in a
social network you might add a friend
but I think probably companies keep a
lot of other metadata that they're
interested in maintaining in the graph
so
uh yeah so like I guess like the
question is like should this update scan
trade-off be a weighted function and if
so what the
way I mean if you can do better in both
then like I guess fine but like could
you pay one for the other in
you great
thanks